NADLER AND SCHIFF BALLOON IN THE
MACY'S'S PARADE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ANOTHER REASON TO
BE WORRIED ABOUT 2020.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SURGING
SUPPORT AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IT HAS LIBERALS NERVOUS
INCLUDING THIS WARNING FOR BLACK
TRUMP SUPPORTERS:
I DON'T THINK WE CAN TAKE
CHANCES ON A PRESIDENT WHO IS
PUTTING MONEY IN OUR POCKETS BUT
ROLLING BACK OUR CIVIL RIGHTS.
JOINING ME NOW IS HORACE COOPER
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK HOW TRUMP IS
MAKING BLACK AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
ALONG WITH 3
ALONG WITH A, LEO A CIVIL RIGHTS
ATTORNEY.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
>> I LAUGHED.
IF PEOPLE WERE GIVEN A CHANCE TO
BE RICH, THEY WOULD SAY NO, NO,
I WANT TO HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
THAT A LANDLORD CAN'T SAY TO A
TENANT YOU ARE A SHE WHEN YOU
THINK THEY ARE A HE.
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE
PRIORITY FOR BLACK AMERICA OR
ANY GROUP OVER PROSPERITY.
GET REAL!
IF THAT'S THE PLAN, PLAN TO BE
VERY SAD ON ELECTION DAY NEXT
NOVEMBER.
>> LEO, THIS IS A PANEL OF
AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS ON
COMEDY CENTRAL ON THE DAILY
SHOW.
TRYING TO MOCK SOME OF THE
VOTERS.
WATCH WHAT THEY DISCOVERED.
>> DONALD TRUMP, HE'S BEEN
HANGING AROUND BLACK PEOPLE AS
LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER.
THEY LOVED HIM UNTIL HE RAN FOR
PRESIDENT.
TRUMP WAS THE MAN.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU THINK TRUMP
WILL WIN IN 2020?
>> TRUMP 2020 BABY.
>> LEO, YOUR REACTION?
EVERYBODY BUT ONE SAID TRUMP
WOULD WIN
>> MY REACTION IS SIMPLE.
THAT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
HERE'S A NEW FLASH.
LESS THAN 9% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS VOTED FOR
TRUMP IN 2016.
IT WILL GET LESS.
BACK TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> IT IS TRUE.
I WILL CHALLENGE YOU.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE DIGNITY AND
EQUALITY.
WHY DO WE HAVE LESS WEALTH THAN
WHITE HOUSE?
ANSWER THAT FOR ME.
>> OKAY, LET HIM ANSWER IT.
>> LET ME GIVE YOU DIGNITY.
THAT'S WHEN YOUR INCOME STARTS
TO ADVANCE AND ADVANCES FASTER
THAN ANY OTHER RACIAL GROUP IN
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THE LAST
3 YEARS.
WHEN YOUR EMPLOYMENT RATE
EXCEEDS THAT OF EVERY OTHER
GROUP.
THE MARCH ON WASHINGTON THAT
MARTIN LUTHER KING SPOKE AT --
>> HE CHANGED THE SUBJECT.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> HE CHANGED THE SUBJECT.
>> JOBS, JOBS, IN AMERICA
DIGNITY COMES FROM HAVING A JOB.
>> HE DIDN'T ANSWER IT.
>> OKAY.
>> TIME OUT.
!
I AM THROWING A YELLOW FLAG.
I WANT TO PICK UP ON SOMETHING
LEO SAID.
HE SAID AND HE IS RIGHT 8% OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS VOTED FOR
TRUMP IN 2016.
HOWEVER A NEW POLL FINDS THAT
TRUMP ENJOYED A 34.5% APPROVAL
RATING AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
THAT'S UP FROM 17.8% LAST MONTH.
WHAT IS HAPPENING LEO?
THIS IS DANGEROUS TERRITORY FOR
THE DEMOCRATS?
>> A MASSIVE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
APPROVAL AND ACTUALLY WHO YOU
WILL VOTE FOR.
AS FAR AS VOTING FOR TRUMP,
THAT'S DISTINGUISHABLE FROM THE
APPROVAL RATING.
HE WON'T GET MORE THAN 8 OR 9%
IN THE UPCOMING ELECTION.
I DON'T WANT ANY JOB.
I WANT THE SAME JOB THAT ANYBODY
REGARDLESS OF RACE, COLOR, OR
SEX.
WHAT HORACE DIDN'T DO IS ANSWER
MY QUESTION.
>> I AM ASKING THE QUESTIONS.
THE 34.5%, THE REPORTS SHOW IF
THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T SECURE 85 TO
90% OF THE AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTE
THE NATIONAL ELECTION IS OVER.
IF THE PRESIDENT PEELS AWAY 20%,
HE WINS.
HOW MUCH OF A REALITY DOUBLE
THAT IS?
>> THAT'S A POLITICAL ATOM BOMB.
IF YOU SEE THE NUMBERS WE SAW IN
GEORGIA AND IN FLORIDA AND IN
TEXAS WHERE BLACKS ENDED UP
BEING THE DECIDING VOTE FOR WHO
ENDED UP WINNING THE STATE-WIDE
RACE.
>> HE DIDN'T ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
>> THE REASON IS BLACK AMERICANS
ARE INTERESTED --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> OVER DINNER.
>> WE ARE GOING TO RUTH CHRIS'S.
>> AND YOU ARE TAKING ME WITH
YOU.
>> TO WIN IN AMERICA YOU HAVE TO
APPEAL WITH A WINNING AGENDA
THAT INCLUDE JOB.
ONLY DONALD TRUMP IS DOING IT
NOW.
IF THE OTHER SIDE DOESN'T DO IT,
YOU COULD END UP SEEING 12 OR
EVEN 18%.
>> OKAY.
>> I BET DINNER FOR THAT.
>> RUTH CHRIS I AM MAKING THE
RESERVATION.
JENNIFER LOPEZ WILL PERFORM AT
THE SUPER BOWL HALF-TIME SHOW.
THIS BEING FOOTBALL SEASON.
SHE TOLD THE "L.A. TIMES" IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR TWO LATINO WOMEN
TO HEADLINE THE SUPER BOWL
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW IN TRUMP'S
AMERICA.
DID WE NEED J-LOTO REMIND US
THERE ARE LATINOS IN AMERICA.
ISN'T THIS POLITICIZING
FOOTBALL?
>> THIS IDENTITY POLITICS IS
HURTING THE LEFT AND
PROGRESSIVES.
HER ACTIONS JUST FULFILLED THAT.
MORE AND MORE OF US ARE SAYING
WE ARE JUST PEOPLE.
WE WANT TO WATCH FOOTBALL AND
ENJOY THANKSGIVING.
>> BRAVO FOR J-LO, BECAUSE THIS
PRESIDENT, SHE NEEDS TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE NOT FORGETTEN.
ALL PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> IF SHE'LL BE THE